das herzlich willkommen zu diesem video
gespielt heute was thomas sagt ich bin
heute mittag das grab außerdem der gute
weg ging was geht also nicht fest dass
jetzt einmal aus ich sage halt thomas
gesagt und dann müssen wir das machen
was ich gesagt habe und wenn ich halt
nichts thomas sagte vor sage dann dürfte
es halt nicht machen und wenn es
trotzdem macht dann muss ich euch leider
fehlen um ist alles mal zu testen will
jetzt mal sagen
thomas sagt kannst ja das tanzen alle
bis okay ist hat es jeder stark alles
klar dann sage ich mal thomas sagt
komplett seehofer auf die geile
eisfläche und da muss es schon mein
erstes album vielleicht mal thomas sagt
bleibt am anfang stehen und ich kurse
jetzt mal ein bisschen drüber und regal
was man hier alles machen kann
ich komme hier steht alles auf der
plattform thomas sax stellt euch alle
auch hinter diese 2 booster was man der
luchs konto ok
thomas sagt der letzte der am ende der
eisfläche ist stirbt mal gucken ja die
beiden sind auf jeden fall deutlich
voraus aber darum ging es erst nur wo
der mann springt zurück manche legen
zurück ja wäre zu überlegen muss
zurückkommen
ich bin nicht da wo wir das war klar ok
ich glaube ich habe schon den letzten
kommen wir her da ist noch niemand
machen danke johannes danke dass du
dabei warst so kann sich jeder über
leben alles klar dann würde ich mal
behaupten wir gehen jetzt zu einem
baskets weil das ist eine richtige holen
so eine aktion die region gemacht und
die machen jetzt auch mal was soll ich
machen ja ich mag sagen bekommen
was weißt du was sagt gesagt 'ja ja wo
wird das nächste leben des handelns
stehen geblieben ist
thomas sagt stellt euch alle auf diese
baumstämme drauflegen sagt alle auf
diese baumstämme drauf
thomas sagte im schnee als weißen
motorradhelm
wird mal ein basketballkorb du hast drei
versuche wenn du es nicht schaffst mich
zu tun
[Musik]
mach jetzt kriegt schon mal ein schuss
da war ganz klar schoss max 1 es macht
echt spaß leute zu töten alt ist immer
noch feucht wieder geil thomas sagt wir
sollen uns nochmal alle vor diese
eisbahn thomas sagt rutz ist alle auf
die eisbahn und hat eine menge spaß für
ein gutes kann
[Musik]
thomas sagt stellt euch wieder alle vor
die bahn da wo wir vorhin angefangen
haben dann zog ich mir jetzt mal zwei
raus und ihr macht dann betteln als
erster von den beiden nicht aussuchen
werde diese konstruktion hat bauen kann
hierzu und dann hier so ein dach drauf
ist als erster schafft der überlebt der
andere halt nicht und thomas sagt einmal
du hier job galaxy skin gemacht und
thomas einmal lux du baust du bist hier
thomas sagt baut das gebäude was da
vorne steht in 32 angst
der eine hat sich angebaut
der junge hat sich eingebaut aber junge
[Musik]
tut mir leid lux müssen doch geil ich
hab noch keinen fall
schade schade thomas sagt alle mit einer
kopfbedeckung ein schritt nach vorne
thomas sagt allem einer kopfbedeckung
nochmal einen schritt nach vorne ist ja
eine kopfbedeckung nicht so war dann
thomas sagt alle mal mitkommen zum
flugzeug
thomas sax sollte ich mal alle hier in
einer reihe auf zu den anderen
thomas sagt einmal grün weißen im
schnitt links und thomas sagt du mit dem
gelben outfit ihr beide sucht euch jetzt
mal im flugzeug und thomas sagt ihr
beide fliegt jetzt in die luft wenn ich
gross ag liefert ihr euch beide ein
battle dem grünen flugzeug das sdk
jaja bruder thomas sagt gegen hat auf
jeden fall park
hits am start als wir kriegen aber die
gehen würde
looping und ja alles runter gesprochen
ich glaube genau da müsst ihr euch beide
jetzt auf dem boden an der spitze gute
mann 20 hier gewohnt wurde man immer
sagt es hat euch alle wieder in die
reihe genau ist ein zugang
vielen dank pittsburgh jack oder bicek
thomas sagt thomas sagt hinstehen
entstehen was hingegen durch ein leben
thomas sagt haerlin sowas sagt spring
den knien springt
[Musik]
da bot der baustelle beste name übergab
der baustelle hat verpackt 1905 alle
läuft ja mal thomas sagt mitkommt das
hat ganz knapp eigentlich bei diesem
schreiben möchte also der king wirklich
jetzt klappt als man sich neben also ich
weiß nicht wohin soll's thomas sagt ford
einmal alle hier ins dorf hinein beginnt
jetzt mal zu ein paar bäumen und dann
machen wir ein duell wer als erstes
einen baum abhaut aber zuerst es vor
sagt stock ok thomas sagt hinkel
thomas sagt aufstehen hin knien
thomas sagt tanzen gut all der die
letzten fünf alle recht setzen eine
herausforderung thomas sax stellt euch
alle vor dem baum gut wenn ich drei
gesagt habe dürfte ja anfangen den baum
abzubauen und wer als letzter den bayern
abgebaut stirbt 3
einer noch nicht mal angefangen sagt ich
habe also 3 also ich habe also man muss
sagen ich hab mal gesagt so thomas sagt
hinkel sagt aufstehen müssen noch
mitmachen ja sogar spagat perfekt es war
die mode machen ja kommt macht mache
jetzt noch kommen er macht jetzt noch
okay die letzten drei als habt ihr das
ding schon schaukeln oder habt ihr die
strafe er denn habe ich habt ihr das
alle ich hab ihn wenn ich runter geht's
halt habe dann macht er das wäre die
niedrigste zahl hat stirbt okay thomas
sagt 3 2 173 welches 0
[Musik]
vielen dank dass du dabei warst immer
perfekt habe jetzt noch zwei werte
kannst also ja ich bin schon weg also
jetzt noch mal auf zufrieden hier bist
du ich bin ja nur eine sache gemacht
dreimal mussten ist das jetzt im ok
thomas sagt ingrid bauer jetzt wird's
knapp wir sind auch die letzten zwei
decken gesamtstadt und der nerd ist nach
dem start wir machen jetzt mal so im
wald sprung ding thomas sagt ihr müsst
beide jetzt über diese rampe hier
springen mit dem booster und wer am
weitesten gesprungen hat der hat
gewonnen
der andere hat verloren thomas sagt
dating beginnt in 321 alter bist du okay
thomas sagt der nerd renten darf
anfangen 3 2 1 wo warst du würdest du
einmal heranzubringen und darfst du
machen jeder das gemacht mit ich kann es
auch mal was auf null
naja da wenn wir gewonnen also bist du
pixel
ich würde sagen das was mit dieser folge
von thomas sagt vielen dank an robert
dating und jannis und simon rolfes ein
zu machen schaut auf jeden fall bei aldi
zog vorbei der dabei war den alten omega
das kinderrennen geschissen hat und
damit ich sagen bis zum nächsten mal
ja geil also
[Musik]